上课啊，今天加一课，咱们抓紧时间速战速决。现在是早上我赶紧上完，我得上班去。
但是为什么着急加一节呢？加一节什么内容呢？
就是关于同学们的。
作业。
这个问题。
咱们刚开始上课的时候啊。
我留过几次作业，为什么要留作业呢？
因为编剧这个。
学问啊这个教学呀你必须得练习。
你得动手，你得大量的写才能真正的去掌握。
他不是听相声，你多听几回就明白了，这种态度不可取啊，说到底你得写呀，对吧？你得会写，你得能写，你得爱写呀。
所以我是留过作业的。
留作业。
按理说我留的量也不大。
因为那点练习量对于学习远远不够。
然后早期的时候呢，同学们写了作业，我都是收上来，然后批改一下的。
这是当时的情况。
为什么呢？因为当时的情况是咱们的学生。
只有。
四十几个吧，我记得对吧？刚开始上课的时候。
有四十几个学生。
那你们的作业我是可以挨个看一看，批一批，改一改点一点。
但是没想到你说现在。
这个有多少人看这个课，咱们是没法统计，也不知道。但是在学习群里，现在就有3000个同学。
我手里的作业已经积压了1000多份。
1000多份什么概念啊？同学们。
不是我不给你们看，不给你们改。很多同学叭叭的经常还提醒我，老师，我的作业你看了吗？
你让我怎么回，我已经找不到你的作业了，其实1000多份作业。
假设一一份是两个小时的量，一个电影。
我看。
批改想就得四五个小时，100份作业，我一年也批不完，我全职全职工作一年也批不完。同学们。
所以其实计划没有变化快，现在就是这么个情况。
对吧现在就是这么个情况。
但是我毕竟是个老师呀，I'm a teacher，对不对？我不能。
完全不管你们。
然后呢，我看了一些作业。
也结合一些我以前批改作业的经验。
我决定今天给大家加一节什么课呢？
就是我把大家作业里面的共性。
错误的共性提炼出来，给大家统一的讲一讲。
然后大家自己去看看自己有没有犯这样的问题，有则改制，无则加勉。
就是就是这一刻就是准备干这个。
相当于是什么大家都容易犯的错。
都容易踩的坑。
我帮大家。
跳一跳坑，躲一躲坑好吧，这节课就这么个内容，所以相当于是帮大家群批一下这个测大家的作业好不好？那这节课咱们就。
咱们就跳一下坑，好吧，然后。
学习一下大家的作业。
同学们交上来的作业啊。
水平肯定是参差不齐的。
有是初学者，有呢是呃现在已经是在业内已经有作品了，还有的呢纯属爱好者。
所以犯的错误出现的问题也不尽相同。
我也不可能说今天一节课就给大家全部把所有的坑都跳了。我也是今天早晨。
尽量的。
发挥我的经验，我在实战中遇到过的这些问题，看到过的这些状况，我尽量的给大家提炼。如果有不全的，我们再补充，我们以后课里再说。今天先给大家这个这个在我上班之前啊，我今天这个这个呃上班之前我赶紧给大家讲一讲，讲完我得我得我得赶紧。
赶紧走吧。
所以今天就没有闲玩了，没有相声了，好吧，不扯淡了啊。
第一个问题直接进入主题啊。
选材。
选材是最重要的问题啊。
或者是说你是你的面临的第一件事情啊，就是这个选材问题。
大部分同学在选材的时候。
还是在基于自己。
我曾经说过啊。
我说很多人的第一个作品是写自己。
男的写小流氓。
女的写谈恋爱，校园爱情、青春爱情，为啥呢？因为你就活了这点岁数。
你认为。
女生就认为自己的某一段爱情或者第一段爱情是自己人生。
最灿烂的时刻。
男生就认为自己蹲在路边抽烟打架。
的那几年是自己人生的高光。
为啥呢？你年轻啊。
你还没过过好日子，你也没过过精彩的生活。
所以呢就往往从自己下手。
不是不行，但我在课上说了，说，我说你在在创作的时候啊。
尽量先不要这么做。
为啥呢？
大容易出现一个什么样的问题，就大家的选材啊太自我。
要么是写自己，明显有自己的影子，他不说是自己，但你也能看出来他写自己，一个叛逆的少年，对吧？父母不理解我，我在学校里怎么样，一看就是在写自己。
就是选材过于自我，要么是自己，要么是自己身边的朋友的结合。
有个什么样的问题啊？我跟你们说，同学们就是除了你以外啊。
没人觉得这个事儿精彩。
容易出现这个问题，但是呢你又不自知。
你觉得很有趣。
你觉得很精彩，但是观众没有兴趣。
为啥会出现这种情况啊？
就是你选材太自我，为啥会出现这种情况？
就是因为你的代入太深了。
我给大家举个例子吧。
我作为一个编剧。
曾经有。
在我人生中，曾经有无数个人。
来找到我，或者听说我是编剧之后跟我说。
哎，我给你提供个素材。
绝对你们编剧写写不出来的素材，想破脑袋也写不出来素材，非常的精彩。就是我身边一个朋友，或者是我亲身经历的一个事情。
然后呢，他就觉得这个事情无比的精彩。
他就要免费的讲给我听，甚至他认为对我是一个礼包，大礼包送给我的。
但我听了之后呢，就觉得这个故事极其的平淡，极其的无聊。
为什么会有这种情况呢？
就是因为你讲的这件事情，你觉得有趣，或者你和你那几个朋友觉得非常的有趣，他是有前提的。
前提是你们之间几十年的交情，几十年的人物设定和几十年的人物关系。
你才会觉得某个人发生了某件事情，真他妈好笑，真他妈有意思，真精彩。
但是你在电影当中。
我们没有这个前提，没有这个人物关系的情况下，你这个事情就不精彩了。
反过来说，如果电影能表现出你们之间的那么几十年的人物关系和人物设定的话，那很多事情都可以精彩，都比这个精彩。
明白这个意思吧？所以千万不要太自我。
我还可以给大家举个例子啊。
我刚刚编剧的时候。
我爸。
也跟我说过类似的话，说啊，你当编剧了，哎呀，太好了。我有一肚子的故事要告诉你。
说你有什么故事？农村长大了，对吧？有没有经历过任何大风大浪？
然后他说谁说的，然后他就。
开始给我讲，他年轻的时候。
在生产队。
对吧初中的时候怎么那老师怎么嫌弃他，然后进入生产队，生产队队长如何的。
迫害他。
对吧打压他。
然后我就听着我就然后就说那是啊我就讲的感觉就是他是那个大时代的弄潮而如何经历那个时代，然后他自己。
就上二两酒，就讲的眉飞色舞。
然后我实在是觉得非常的平淡无奇。
对吧生产队的队长。
祸害你充其量就是瞧不上你。
而且瞧不上你，是因为你偷小猪啊。
是吧也并没有说。
你经历的何等的大风大浪，实在是平淡无奇，但是没有办法。
他本位主义他从他自我的角度，他就会觉得难道不够你写进剧本里面吗？
对吧咱们的很多同学就犯了这个选材的错误，过于自我，过于身边就会导致除了你或者你朋友以外，你你知道这个事儿的朋友以外。
没有人有兴趣听这件事情。
去给别人哇，大学同学啊，有一个宿舍，我们宿舍有个人特别格儿，哎，特别有意思。
真的就你觉得有意思而已。
好吧，所以这个选材。
是第一个坑，我们跳的第一个坑，大家在练习的时候。
尽量别写自己。
尽量别写自己，别写身边人。
差点意思。
当然啊当然啊。
或许真的有某个同学经历过大风大浪。
成为过时代的弄潮儿。
有可能的，但是几率不大，我们绝大部分人都是自我感觉自己人生。
命运多舛，自我感觉自己是不一样的烟火，跟任何人都不一样。我有我自己的故事，我有我自己的心路历程。
大部分人都这么想自己，但大部分人真的不是，就是很普通而已，好吗？
如果你非得写自传体，非得写回忆录。
我是比较推荐。
70岁那年开始动笔，好吧。
选材问题。
很多同学在这里上来就。
走歪了，所以这个坑先给大家说一下，好吧。
第二个问题，紧挨着选材。
哎。
就是苦难。
我们同学。
写的故事。
有3分之1强。
超过3分之1。
在描写苦难。
一路走来真他妈的不容易。
多么的悲惨。
谈惨惨。
说呢。
我的确。
在人物设定的那里。
讲人物的那一节课，我曾经说过。
主角要一定程度的可怜。
那只是一个人设的一方面，明白我意思吗？就塑造这个人物的时候的一方面。
绝不是让你们以苦难为主题。同学们。
我们不能一路苦难呀。
我们这帮同学，你们到底是经历过什么？
你他妈这人生怎么了？哪有那么多苦难可写啊。
有3分之1的同学写。
家庭。
老师如何邻居如何，环境如何，对吧？痛苦，然后流浪，不被理解，才华被埋没，对吧？
都是这种。
非常苦难，非常灰色的一。
这这这这。
这个调调。
好吧。
我在这里。
跟大家说一下啊。
我看着这些同学作品，我其实我其实发现了一个什么问题呢？我想跟大家说什么呢？
就是苦难和不被理解。
不是。
艺术家的必须。
明白我这个意思吗？就有很多同学啊把苦难和不被理解那种孤独那种哎呀，我孤独，我不被理解，我苦认为是一个艺术家的。
必要条件，因为艺术家就应该等于苦难。
等于不被理解，等于孤独，等于各色。
等于不修边幅，胡子拉叉。
我是那样的呀。
好吧，这个偏了。
就是艺术不应该是你发泄的地方或者倒苦水的地方。
两码事。
纵然是生活真的有苦难。
生活里面真的是有苦难，这个我们当然承认。
纵然是现在生活一片全是苦难。
那我们作为。
文艺工作者。
我们也应该描述希望。
描述旧赎啊。
即便生活全是苦难。
我们也不应该。
是发牢骚的人吧。
对不对？
所以这个苦难啊。
我当然不能禁止大家去写。
但是我真的不提倡。
我不提倡同学们描绘苦难。
因为我担心很多同学误以为苦难等于艺术。
苦难的人等于艺术家。
我怕有这个问题，你知道吗？
这让我想到了一个什么？你如说我特别担心这个苦难的问题，让我想到什么，你知道吗？
果想到小鸟了。
然我想到抽象艺术。
头像艺术呀，就是我在这儿啊教大家画画，我说画画应该这样画，应该那样画色彩应该这样，对吧？透视应该这样，线条应该这样。然后呢。
有个同学就直接老师。
那个巴黎的拍卖会上昨天成交了一幅画，1500万美元。
那幅画呢就是拿红色油漆泼满画布，然后用黄色油漆点了个点，抽象艺术大师谁谁谁画的。比如说库布里克画的。
对吧库布里克。
也是描绘一些苦难嘛，就来抽象大师某某某画呀。
1500万美金。
老师我要画那幅画。
你明白我意思吧？
就他画画不好好学。
但是他觉得大师根本不需要好好画画，大师就是拿油漆一泼，然后点了个点，我就要当大师，我就要泼油漆，然后卖1500万美金。
学们，你们太幼稚了。
你们根本不知道抽象艺术是什么。
你们根本不知道那些话。
为什么那么高的价钱？
有多少人参与，那是一个什么样的局？
有多少白钱黑钱、红钱、绿钱在里面滚动。
那些艺术家你也不知道他们之前经历了什么。
你也不知道他们到底是操盘手还是棋子。
它是一个圈子，它是一套系统，它是一个局，它是一种玩法，跟你没有关系。
不是不是说你能画出那幅画，你也应该卖1500万美金。然后别人不给你这个钱，你就哎呀，你们都不懂艺术，我也要生气了，我也我是艺术家。
你现在在描写苦难，你不就是在做这种事情吗？
你不就是在硬装艺术家吗？
你能不能先把故事讲好，讲一个精彩的故事，昂扬的故事。
对吧我当然知道有大师在搞苦难。我当然知道，就像我知道有个大师的话卖了1500万美金一样。
但是你不知道人家怎么玩的，你也不知道人家那1500万美金到底买的是不是那幅画。
对吧所以你不要去模仿，很多同学就是不服劲儿，老师觉得老师你讲的这些入门级的，我对标库布里克。
那你就像往画布上泼油漆，然后想让别人1500万美元买走一样愚蠢。
好吗？所以我强烈的不推荐。
大家去描绘苦难，即便是我们生活的社会，真的苦难重重。
我也希望大家。
去发现希望。
去歌颂救赎。
好吧。
第二点。
第三点。
老生常谈的一个问题。
主人公的共情问题。
主角的共情问题，老生常谈的一个问题。
就是做不好，就是没整明白，就是没有共情，你怎么办？同学们呐，你们的主人公，你们的主角没有共情。
这个问题我是在课上也是非常严肃的说的，大篇幅的说的，我们主角需要做到哪些事情，让他有共情。
除了课上说了，课上说的，我就不再说了，大家自己去回看。好吧，我再说几个。
新问题大家犯的别的错误。首先，优点缺点不明确。
优点缺点不明确，就是你的人设呀。
嗯。
不具体。
这么说吧，就不具体。比如说你说他有个优点。
比如是。
优点是很。
很勤奋，这不具体勤奋不具体，你得具体成特别爱做某一件什么样的事情。
比较勤奋。
然后呢，这个这个这个。
比如说你认为他的缺点是很粗心。
不具体。
你要上来让他忘了一件很重要的事情，很具体的事情，对吧？忘了老婆的生日，对不对？就是你的优缺点呀。
现在不具体，大而化之，这个对共情是有损失的。
这是。
呃，我发现了一些新问题，然后再就是。
这个这个你的目标行动线的问题。这个我们在课上说过了，在这里再次强调你的目标一定要被认可。
特别是你上来的第一个目标。
如果不被认可。
那你整个片子就垮了。
好吗？我们很多同学犯这个问题上来做的第一件事情。
莫名其妙。
莫名其妙，不知道你想要干什么。
不知道你为什么要这么做。
就是这个目标不明确，没有道理，没有共情。
然后就导致你行动线也很无力，很散。
对吧也就是我们说的这个主角的决定经常很愚蠢。
就实让观众就是。
愚蠢他就不可爱了，你明白我意思吗？就是主角有时候做出错误的决定是没有关系的，不要做出愚蠢的决定。
因为错误的决定是可爱的，愚蠢的决定，那就是愚蠢了。
好吧，就是这个关于这个主角的共情，我在课上那么反复强调这件事情，我没有想到我们同学们。
除了我在课上讲了洋洋洒洒主角如何共情。其中有一个小点，我说主角要可怜好嘞。
就做到了这一点，然后这个主角无限的可怜。
孙姓苦海，我的天哪，其他全部管了。
这怎么行呢？主角的共情一定要给我保住啊。
对不对？
甚至我还在课上说了，我说有时候你他妈你主角起名字都能耽误你的。
共琴对吧？我说你起名字最好都用点呃常见字儿，常用字儿。你如果想有个性，就用常用字，但不不常用在名字里的那种字儿，对吧？我还举个例子教个方法。
因为我生怕同学们交上来的。
这个这个剧本里面全是这种齐天豪，对吧？这这个这个这种琼瑶式的名字，甚至复姓，对吧？这呃欧阳端木令狐都出来了。
哎。
但是我跟你们说啊，同学们。
现实往往比我预测的更残酷。
我在这里不点名的说一个同学交上来的剧文。
他的男女主角起的名字。
不光是琼瑶的问题，超越了琼瑶，也超越了富姓。
我没有说复性不好啊，同学们。
腹线生活中当然有，虽然很少，但是当然有，但是你不能因为你是偶像剧好家伙出来的角色都是复线儿，对吧？生活中有，但没有那么多，我是这个意思，我并不是说复线不好听。
我就说回这个同学啊。
生活真的。
现实真的。
都是你想象不到的同学们，你们知道他起的什么名字吗？
男主角姓罗。
女主角姓戴。
听到这里。
没什么大的问题。
男主角姓罗。
叫robo。
女主角姓戴，叫戴安娜。
我当时我就问这个同学，where are you from?
Hey where are you from?
你想干什么呀？你呀。
他罗伯特与戴安娜。
你想干什么呀？
就为了呢。
就为了让别人感觉你的故事很洋气，是吧？
还罗伯特语带来娜，哎呦，我的天。
改掉这些坏习惯啊，就主人公的共情。
一定要做好。
回去回去回看一下我。
我讲主角的那一节课好吗？关于主人公这里啊，我再多说一句啊，因为我发现好几个同学犯这个错误，主人公主人公。
主角主角他有他的目标，他有他的行动力。
他最后。
必须是解决问题的那个人。
核心问题必须是他解决。
明白这个意思吧？
核心问题必须是主角亲自解决，不要给我举返例，不要给我犟。
核心问题主角亲自解决。
因为我发现有好几个同学不约而同的写了一个什么样的情节啊，令我崩溃。
就是你的这个男主角，好家伙也是一路苦难，哎，各种颠沛流离，在商场打拼，对吧？在人世间浮沉，经历了无数的挫折。
面对各种各样的问题，巨大的经济压力，有好几个同学不约而同的写了同一个情节，我也不知道是为什么，就突然有一个女孩爱上了这个男主角。这个女孩呢是个富二代，不顾父亲的反对，一定要嫁给这个男孩。
一定要嫁给这个主角。
他的父亲肯定是不同意呀，对吧？肯定是不同意，然后威逼利诱，甚至使用暴力，但是都拆不散这一对绝命鸳鸯。
然后这个女孩嫁给这个男孩之后，这个父亲突然发现这个男孩身上是有闪光点的，然后给了他一大笔钱。
结束。
解决了所有的问题。
天外来财，你知道吗？而且还是一个美女。
这个这个这个扛着一马带钱，踩着七彩云就来找你了，是吧？
哪那么些好事儿呢？
哪那么些好事儿啊？
写这样情节的同学。
你是平常一直在做这个梦，是吧？
不行啊，你平常做这个梦可以，生活中可能可以实现，对吧？你去找一个有钱的老丈人，没有问题。但是在故事中，主角必须亲手解决问题。
好吧，亲自解决问题，不要这样。
对手的问题。
对手问题。
我们大部分同学啊因为。
可能也是因为选材艺的问题，苦难的问题，就写的东西很写实，就偏写实嘛。偏写实的时候，大家就不愿意造对手。
不愿造一一个对手，不愿造明确对手，为啥呢？因为写诗篇的对手确实就是比较计时的片子，就是你很难出现一个特别大的大坏蛋，一定要跟你干，一定要一路欺负你。对手往往是。
是实是比较分散的。
好几个对吧？或者是这个一路走来，不同阶段有不同的对手。
所以关于这个对手的问题。
我想也给大家提醒一下，绝大部分同学的作业里面。
对手都是不够的。
有一半左右甚至没有对手。
对手过于松散。
不具体。
我。
推荐大家在练习的时候。
可以先从一个对手入手，而且这个对手必须是人。
明白这个意思吧？
从一个对手入手，对于初学者，我是不推荐大家把大最后的大对手设成自己的，就自我与自我的战斗嘛。
嗯，外界对你给给你的苦难，给你的那几个对手都是虚假的，最后是跟自己的战斗。我是不推荐大家上来就这么做的，容易很散。
容易你这个对手不给力，所以我推荐大家写什么呢？
写。
一个对手，而且对手是人。
然后呢，让这个对手。
从观众的角度看。
坏到家。
让这个对手从他自己的角度看无比正确。
就是让对手自圆其说。
是非常重要的。
因为为什么呢？因为你设一个无限坏的对手，容易让这个对手脸谱化。
就他不真实了。但是呢你设计这样一个对手，那从他的角度他又没错喽。
从他的角度，他又没错了。
对不对？
你现在觉得你做的这件事情。
非常正义。
对不对？
我们说我们是药神。
我不是药神，其实就是偏纪时风格了，他的对手相对较松。但是我不是药神，是一个偏纪时风格的商业篇，纪时风格只是它的定律。他。
的根本还是一个商业片，所以他的对手是人也是非常明确的。我跟你讲，我不需要什么的对手是谁？
我不是药神，最大的对手是谁？其实是周一围。
只不过周一围后面跟徐峥针锋相对的戏被剪掉了。
明白这个意思吗？让大家感觉好像最大的对手变成了那个那个呃那个那个格列卫药厂的那两个西装人，金丝眼镜的西装坏蛋，对吧？药厂的呃那个那个代表卖卖药，卖几万块钱一瓶，就把他们塑造成最大的坏蛋。然后嘞。
还有一个坏蛋，就是那个。
卖假药的那个江湖骗子穿的白大褂的那江湖骗子。
这个对手变成他们了。其实从剧本的角度。
我不是药神，最大的对手，是周一围演的那个警察那个角色。我跟你讲为什么？
我跟你讲为什么？
为什么他是最大的对手？
第一。
你们看这个人物设定。
徐峥是主角。
他要卖药，是他的行动线。
然后阻止他卖药的周一围。
是个警察要抓卖药的。
非法卖药。
一个针锋相对，然后呢。
抓他的这个警察。
跟。
徐峥是什么关系？
设定了什么？
小舅子，而且是前小舅子。
针锋相对。
新人到底是。
到底是大义灭亲？
还是。
什么就是这个设定，你不你没有想起来什么吗？同学们。
没有想起我让你们看的某个剧吗？
绝命毒师呀。
绝命毒师的主角老白贩毒。
他的那个。
那个谁连接。
他的那个链条。
是缉毒警察，明白这个意思吗？这就是设定。
这就是人物关系上商业篇的玩法。
你最大的对手。
是你的小舅子。
所以这个设定一出，当时就已经奠定了周一围必然是第一大对手。我们说对手。
相对于徐峥的行动线来说，那一定是针锋相对的。
也就是我们所说的，让你的对手坏到家。
针锋相对的。
你知道吗？
让你的对手坏到家，因为他跟你的这件事情针锋相对，他是警察，他当然对吧？
他当然要抓你卖药了。
所以说这叫从他的角度，他又无比正确。这就是我跟大家说的意思，明白吧？从徐峥的角度。
他的对手要坏到家，警察呀，而且还是你小舅子，而且你还打过他姐姐。
明白吗？
他可以借着这个。
嗯。
致死你。
但是从周一威的角度，他无比正确。我是警察呀，你卖这个药就是非法的呀，我就是应该抓你呀，对不对？这就是我说的一个漂亮的对手，无比正确的对手。
又是无比坏的对手。
就是这个意思。
为什么举药神这个例子？因为药神就是一个偏纪事风格的。
他的对手相对来说比较散，有好多。
但是最大的对手依然是周一伟，而且周一为在所有的对手当中出场最早。
奠定了他是第一对手的地位，戏份最多。
只不过是审查，因为他这个这个这个角色这个设定这个职业对吧？在审查过程中一定是遭遇了非常大的删减的。好吧，所以说这个对手啊，我是推荐同学们。
看一看自己的剧本，把它具体化一点，具体成人，具体成无比坏的人。但是站在他的角度又是无比正确的自圆其说的。站在主角的角度，他是无比坏的这样一个。
对手，然后还要注意一点什么呢？
什么叫对手呢？就是主角最大的那次成长和蜕变，是需要在对手的刺激下的。
你不能对手在那跟你干着干着，你插出去跟你女朋友谈恋爱的时候，突然领悟到了一个什么，然后突然变强了，又回去把对手干掉了，不可以对手的意义就是迫使你成长，刺激你成长。所以主角的那次最大的蜕变。
最大的呢是蜕变。
那是成长。
对手的刺激下。
好不好？我们大家都去把自己的对手加强一下，我发现这是个普遍的一个弱项，普遍的一个坑。我们这节课就是要跳坑嘛，好吧，把这些坑都跳过去。还有一个技巧啊，这是书上写的，我突然想到的这个反派这个对手你完全设定好了之后。
他有个自己的这个这个设设定目标，让你的对手啊提前出场。就是他原本你打算在这个位置让他出场，你琢磨一下，可不可以往前再提几场戏，琢磨一下。
试一试，搞不好有奇效哦，为什么让他提前出场，就往前一瞪。
让他提前跟我们的主角见面。
或者是提前的跟观众见面。
会有奇效。
会让他的压迫感时间更长。
对吧危险更。
有个慢慢逼近的感觉，大家可以试一下这个小诀窍，好不好？
关于对手，我就提示这么多。
第5个。
老生常谈的问题啊。
这也是所有所有所有的。
初学者也好，爱好者也好，新人也好，都犯的错误。
就是铺垫太多。
出电太多的问题。
好吧。
这个问题啊真的是老生常谈了。
好难解决啊。
我们的同学就是特别愿意写铺垫。
这个问题怎么解决呢？我怎么说呢？让你们改了呢？
先想一想啊。
首先先做第一点，钱使得不要。
前十的不要。
不要写前使了。
所谓的铺垫啊我。
剧本中是需要有铺垫的。
我没说不要有铺垫，对吧？但是你的铺垫太多，为什么呢？因为你有很多前史。
铺垫铺垫的是什么呀？同学们记得吧。
是现状啊。
是现状，你铺垫，你也铺垫的是现状呀。
你老搞前十干什么？
你老搞小时候干什么？
你要搞他的成长轨迹干什么？
就是铺垫太多。
整体电影铺垫太多，单场戏铺垫还多，每一场戏都有铺垫。
每一场戏的铺垫我在讲单场的时候说过，我说掐头去尾，动作进出，不要啰嗦。
整部戏的来说。
出见太多。
也是这个很。
就特别是同学们写的那个那个那个那个那个大纲啊。
假设1万字的话，5000字再铺点。
就5000字，前面5000字全砍掉才进故事。
就这个问题。
，我们就还说刚才那个说过药神。
药神因为它有点计时风格啊，它的铺点其实也是偏多的。
但那就是极限了，大家去看一下。
徐峥这个角色上来。
铺垫了几场戏，我跟你说极其干净，多一场都没有。
第一场他在干什么？
我印象非常深刻。
第一场他在卖药，他在店里卖药。然后。
隔壁老头告诉他，房东又找你了啊。
赶紧交房租吧。
出见了他的身份和经济经济状况。
基本上是铺垫徐峥自己。
第二场戏。
谁？
他爹。
他有个生病的爹，需要医疗费。
第三场。
他儿子。
离婚的儿子跟着老婆的，然后带他儿子出去还。
还。
阿忠连充胖子给儿子3万块360块钱，让他买鞋。
第三场戏，前妻跟前妻谈判离婚。
儿子的抚养权。
而呃前期要跟着相当于老公移民国外。
就这么4刀5场戏，干干净净的铺垫。
然后打了那个那个推搡中推了他前期第六场还是第五场。
让凡凡一出场。
进局子了吗？
因为碰了他前妻把他前妻撞倒了。
进了公安局，被律师报警，进了公安局周一围出场来揍他。
干不干净？
出电了这么5到6场戏，徐峥这个角色所有的人物关系，所有的现状，最要他命门的几个人。
他爹他前妻，他儿子。
都交代了，然后顺便小舅子出场最大的对手。
然后下一场戏就直接是传军了。
全军就来找。
呃，就吕秀义这个角色就来找呃徐峥了。
呃，你。
在印度有路子，可不可以帮我带点药，对吧？我是个白血病患者。
这是是你这场戏既可以归在。
现状里也可以归在激励的开始。当然也有人把激烈开始从下一场开始算，就是他老老爹。
发病需要。
需要一笔钱做手术，有有人从激励从那场戏开始也OK也OK把吕受义这个这场戏作为前提也可以。
也可以把吕受益这场戏认为是激利的开始都没问题。我什么意思呢？就是你看这这部电影的铺垫算多的吧，算多的真的算多的啊，现状交代的算多的，而且是很刻意的。
咚咚咚咚咚一场戏一个人很刻意的，可以这么说啊。
当然我可以也也可以用褒义词啊，很规很工整，很工整的做了铺垫。
这种算多的。
算极限了，你不能再多。
不能再多了。
就是现状的问题。
电影不就给你讲个故事吗？现状。
激励，然后开始故事就完事了。
老跟以前小时候他爹妈对他好不好，有什么关系啊，对不对？
我们说那个吧。
夏洛特烦恼。
夏洛特烦恼的铺垫也是比较典型的。
对吧现状的没没有。
没有现抓。
上来就是秋雅家了个大款，然后沈腾去参加他的婚礼装富。
然后呢，各种出丑。
直接就是事件开场，很激烈，你不需要知道沈腾家里什么情况。呃，小时候遭遇过什么，沈腾现在在干什么都不需要交代，只是若隐若现的觉得沈腾是在装，他其实并没有钱，什么时候开始铺垫。
玛丽来了以后呀，玛丽来了以后让沈腾走，沈腾不走，在那发飙。玛丽直着鼻子骂，说，你随个礼把我。
对吧我蹬我天天蹬三轮，然后呢呃本来想换个电动的，你随个礼，把我的电动车随进去了，然后装什么装，成天也不上班。
用麻力。
痛骂沈腾。
所有的现状交代就是这么干净。
就是这么痛快，就是这么节省篇幅。
对吧吵架。
夫妻吵架打现状交代。
我们自咱们的片子啊铺垫太多，铺垫太多容易有个什么问题啊？就是你头大身子小，你知道吗？
或者是你身子确实就是弱，你就是因为营养不良，你才能长你才长成了这样。
你就是因为事儿不应啊，同学们啊，你就是因为事儿不应，所以你前面写了个大头。
就是这个问题，你要是事儿硬，你自己你比你要是事儿硬，你比我着急，你绝对不铺垫了，赶紧吧，我要进事了，对吧？我要去抢银行，我要去穿越，我要去干嘛，你事儿硬的话，你前面就没那么多铺垫了。
大家注意一下，好吧，铺垫就是现状。
把有用的现状交代一下，药神的现状就就是缺钱。
他就是缺钱，对吧？他现状不好，他缺钱，所以他才为了卖药铤而走险，这就是我不是药神的铺垫。第六。
关于。
流动性。
在这里再次强调一下啊，剧情的流动性。我们很多同学写的这个故事啊。
真的是在讲故事，你知道吗？
永远在用讲的。
我们说一个电影啊。
必须是事件牵引着我往前走。
你的对话呀最好也是都在事件中完成。
一部电影120分钟。
坐下来聊天。
不要超过三场戏。
我认为啊不要超过三个大厂。
别坐下来嘛？有那么哪有那么多机会坐下来聊天啊。
吃一顿饭还不行吗？
开一次会还不行啊？
为什么总要做下来呢？
你没事儿了，因为是你要用事件牵引。
把事情先都写出来，事情堆的满满的。然后。
再往上装台词儿，你不要动不动就坐下来聊，通过聊天推进剧情，通过聊天推进情感。通过聊天，他俩从。
本来关系挺好。
吃了一顿饭，聊了一顿天儿。
把关系给闹掰，你老是想通过对话。
办大事儿。
对话不要扛er，对话最好是为事件服务就可以了。好吧，就是让你的剧情流动起来。然后每一场戏也是不要状态进状态出。
剧情死了不动了，很多时候剧情都是不动了。所以就注意这一点，其实这理念就是很简单，你就是你用事儿去牵着走事件去迁移，然后呢少坐下来说，更不能陷入问答陷阱。这个咱们在台词那节那节课也反复说过，好吧。
但是这个也是一个贡性的问题。所以在这里。
提出来。
第七个问题，最后一个问题好吧，就是。
情绪单一的问题。
情绪单一。
这个问题我不知道应该怎么去跟大家。
具体的描述和解决啊，就比如说我们同学写的苦难的片子，就喜欢一苦到底。
写喜剧的片子呢就一洗到底。
里面情绪缺乏变化。
其实是这样啊，就一个片子当中啊。
你不能说他是个喜剧片，它里面就没有眼泪。
他是个喜剧片，它里面就没有悬疑。它是个喜剧片，它里面就没有让人紧张的时候。
我们举个例子，比如说。
夏洛特烦恼。
他是个喜剧片吧。
这个穿越题材这个从根儿上它就是个喜剧片，你知道吗？
当然是个喜剧片。
沈头麻丽对吧？这这。
这是这些年质量最高的喜剧片了。
它里面有没有让你哭的？
最后沈腾。
回来以后，抱着玛丽哭的那一段，全场都哭了。
我看的手映，我那时看手映啊，我们单位的，我我也哭了。
很多人都很哭了。
他有让你哭的时候。
他有没有让你着急的时候，揪心的时候。
那个小流氓要。
在小树林里欺负玛丽那一段你不揪心吗？你不着急吗？
对不对？你不紧张吗？
咱们同学的这个现在写的这个东西啊，情绪比较单一。
我推荐大家这样就是。
大家用色块去涂一下自己的这个大纲。比如说。
高兴的场次，你用红色图。
紧张的场次。
你用黄色土对吧？这个悲伤的场次用蓝色土。
你看一下你的色块。
不能太单一不能太单一。
有有所偏重，但是要有所调剂。
即便是再紧张的谍战片儿也好，苦难片儿也好。
他当中也是有。
欢乐时光的呀。
对吧我们讲剧本节拍的时候。
那叫什么游戏时光嘛？
对不对？
我们说菊次郎。
菊次郎的夏天，那么悲伤的片子。
他在路上。
也做了很多好玩的事情啊。
明白这个意思吧？就是注意自己。
整部片子的情绪调节问题。
最好是都有。
再悲伤的片子里面也有某几场戏，是欢乐的，是喜剧的。
这这是观众观影的体验呀。
淘记呀好不好？这个问题我们大家也要去注意一下，我的建议就是你涂涂涂色块。
看看你的片子的情绪的颜色分布漂不漂亮。
有没有问题？
可以以一种为主，喜剧片嘛？以喜剧为主。但是。
你也得让观众感动个两三场吧。
你也得让观众紧张个三五场吧。
你这些的观众平静个三五场吧。
期待个三五场吧。
思考个两场吧。
是不是思考别太多，思考了两场吧。
你看一下你的这个情绪色调的配比。
不要太单一。
不要一苦到底或者一乐到底。
很多劣质的。
喜剧片或者是压抑的呃悲情片。
为什么看的那么不舒服？
就是有这个问题，我们的同学的写现在写的东西就普遍的偏单一。
不舒服。
好吧。
今天我就呃这个这个利用上午这点时间。
先给大家跳这7个坑吧。
先跳这7个以后发现了，我们继续跳。
继续查了五缺，今天就这样好吧，我就走了。
嗯。